التعليم في الصغر كالنقشي على الحجر وربما
بوابه للدخل الاعلى لاحقا الاطفال الذين
يتعلمون جيدا خلال العام الاول من المدرسه
الابتدائيه من المرجح ان يحقق دخلا اعلى
من زملائهم في المستقبل دراسه جديده
اجرتها جامعه درم طبعا هذه الجامعه عريقه
جدا ومعروفه بالتعاون مع وزاره التعليم في
بريطانيا تقول لنا الفصول التمهيديه
الفعاله يمكن ان تساعد الاطفال في
المستقبل على جنه دخلا يتراوح بين
2007,500 جنيه استرليني اكثر من غيرها قال
بحث لان الاستثمار في الفصول التمهيديه
الجيده والمعلمين الكفاء يمكن ان يكون له
عوائد هائله على اقتصاد البلاد في
المستقبل
في الدراسه ان السنوات التي تسبق دخول
الطفل المدرسه لا تقل له اهميه ونتديات
التي يواجهها الصغار الاقل حظا تبدا حتى
قبل التحاقهم بالمدرسه
[موسيقى]
من مصر سالنا الناس عن المعلمين الذين
تركوا اثرا كبيرا في حياتهم متابعه
[موسيقى]
والله يا معلم
وكل الحياه الجميله فيهم
همم بصراحه حاجات كثيره اسد يعني موجوده
في قلبي يعني اتجاهه بصراحه مدرسين
الابتدائي كلهم يعني عندك مستر امجد مثلا
بسم الله ما شاء الله خرجنا كلنا حابين
الرياضه وكان جميل وكان واخدنا كلنا
كاولاد كاخواته بسم الله ما شاء الله غير
مدرسين بصراحه دلوقت كان مستر عربي
كان اسمه مستر حجازي كان يعني كان طيب جدا
وكان عنده همم يعني
طاقه انه هيتقبل الغلط ويعلم ويصحى من غير
ما يغلط في اي طالب او يلم شعره بحاجه
وحشه يعني كان اسمه
الابتدائيه كان شخص كويس جدا وباعتبرنا زي
عياله برده كان بيقعد ينصحنا يعني حاجه
بره التعليم وكده ويدينا نصائح في حياتنا
كان مدرس الرياضه
مساء الحسابيه وهو كان دائما بمعاملته
كويسه معي
دائما استقباله والتشجيع لي ده خلاني احب
طبعا الماده وانا ما كنتش بحبها يعني
[موسيقى]
تيتا
فوزي المونتال
[موسيقى]
موبايل وزو واي واي
بث حي ومباشر من احدى الحضانات في زغرتا
شمال لبنان تكرولين
نشاهد معكم تتكالولين وهي تقرا قصه وحكايه
للاطفال هذه الحكايه تتعلق بالجدات بما
انه يتكلم جده فهي توارث
هذه المهنه على طوال السنين طبعا نتحدث عن
معلمه قديمه يعني معلمه بدات في مهنه
التعليم منذ زمن بعيد وما زالت حتى الان
تقوم بنشر المعلومه ونشر الحب للاطفال في
الحضانات نذهب الى زغرتا وتتكاليلين معنا
يسعد صباحك سكر كارولين
نعم ايه سمعتك قلم تحيه لالك تيتا كارولين
شكرا شكرا جزيلا ميرسي ميرسي
تيته قد ايه بحبوكي يا طلاب
والاطفاله
اكيد كثير بس انا بحبن كمان اكثر واكثر
انا بحبني كثير كثير كل حياتي كنت معهم من
عمري 19 سنه وانا مع الاطفال فكري انه
تقريبا 60 سنه 60 سنه
والطفل بري
ومن برائته نتعلم كثير اشياء بحياتنا
نتعلم كل حاجه حياتنا انه الطفل هو بري
ومستقبليه شو بده يصير هالطفل او بده يكون
رئيس جمهوريه رئيس الوزراء حكينا دكتور
مهند
الاطفال هلا اييه زيكا صاروا اكثر لانه
عندهم ايييه
قديمه ما كان عندنا كل مكان في حضانات ما
كان في الاهتمام الزائد بالطفل هلا كل شيء
صار مستقبل
بالبيت بالمدرسه بالحضانات همم
كله تغير وصاروهن ازكى اكثر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بنفسهم بحاله اكتر من قبل لانه
الحضانه بتعلمنا كثير اشياء من مني طفل
لانه مستقبل يوم الطفل خمس اشهر ست شهور
كبير بقى همم عن نوع معين همم
على الزكاه على اختيارات ما عارفين رفقاته
مع اختلاط مع الكبار مع المعلمات مع اكيد
هالزال غير الجيل
علمني من 20 او 30 سنه
الاطفال هلا الكاميرا شوي شوي عم تمشي
عليهم انا شايفه مشهد هيك غريب علي مش
مقلوف شايفه اطفال عقلين ورايقين شو هي
توجيهات قبل الكاميرا ولا هم من هيك بشكل
عام ههه لا
لا لا لا لا لا الكاميرا اكيد بتاثر علي
ولا اكيد اكيد اكيد
همم الكاميرا متاثر عينيها بس اللي
بالاسمان وقت الدرس كثير بيحبوا ازاي بيحب
بيتعلم
بيحب يتعلم بيحب همم
بالحضانه او بالمدرسه الابتدائيه
بارعين باشغالهم لو ما كانوا مهندسين لو
ما كانوا دكاتره وحكماء واطباء
كتير بالاشغال اللي بياخدوها
كملي شو اذا بشوفوكي شو
انا اذا بشوفوني انا علمت بطرابلس 25 سنه
بنزل على طرابلس اذا بتتعمم بتشوفوني
بالطريق قدني وسيف وشيء غير طبيعي
بيغمروني بتذاكرينا احنا اسفين يعني لحد
هلا فكري انه من 30 سنه 35 سنه
بتذكروني
وبصغرتا زيت
احنا كنا عندك بالمدرسه
حسيت حيل ريحه وظيفه ولا مره بحياتي ولا
نهار الا هي لانها رساله هذه محبه اذا ما
حبيتي الطفل ما فيك تقربي لك لكن طفل
والكان بالمدرسه وين مكان ولا مره حسيت
انه هي وظيف كيف بدي تممها ونروح ولا مره
بحياتي لحد هلا بهالعمر انا فيه بحب
الاطفال غير سكر
ونحن حبي كتير
وبما اننا نتحدث عن المعلم من رام الله
ينضم لنا الاستاذ الجامعي غسان الخطيب
والسرسي جامعه بيرزيت وهو استاذ نادين
خماش اهلا بك يا دكتور احنا رجعناها للدين
على فكره مش عارفه انك موجود معانا واو
اهلا بكم
الدكتور احنا جبناك خصوصي لنعرف مفاجاه
حلوه صباح الخير
والله انا يعني اشعر بالفخر واعتزاز عندما
اشاهد نديم خماش في عملها وهي ناجحه بكل
المقاييس
واتذكر الفتره التي كانت فيها طالبه وتذكر
انها تركت لدي انطباع بانها طالبه واعده
فقد كانت
تلميذه جاده جدا ومجتهده
ولديها حب استطلاع كبير وايضا كان لديها
قدره على توجيه الاسئله الصعبه همم هذا
جزء من ما اتذكر عنها وانك استاذ اشعر
بفخر شديد عندما اشاهد تلاميذي ناجحين
وموفقين في الحياه ونادين هي نموذج همم من
هذه النماذج وهذا هو يعني المردود الاساسي
والاهم همم لاي استاذ بغض النظر اذا كان
استاذ جامعي او استاذ مدرسي او غير ذلك
دكتور واترك الطالبه تحاور دكتوره يعني
انا اعجز عن التعبير وانا فعلا سعيده
وفعلا تفاجات بهذه المفاجاه انت فخر لنا
استاذ غسان الخطيب وفخر لفلسطين وفخر لكل
الطلبه الذين تتلمذوا على يدك ونتحدث كمان
انه نشير بالذكر انه الاستاذ غسان كان
عامل وزير في الاعلام في فلسطين وبالتالي
يعني نحن فخرون بان تكون ضيفنا اليوم في
برنامج صباح العربيه اضافه كبيره في
حياتنا في مسيرتنا التعليميه في جامعه
بيرزيت وايضا اضافه كبيره لنا لتكون على
الهواء مباشره في برنامج صباح العربيه
شكرا لكم شكرا لكم
وزملائك الحقيقه يعني مجرد افراد حلقه
لموضوع التعليم هو بحد ذاته امر في غايه
الاهميه لانه بعد هذه التجارب الطويله
اييه نعتقد بانه من بين متطلبات نهوض
الامم المختلفه والعديده اعتقد بان
التعليم هو المتطلب الاول لانه التعليم هو
الذي يؤدي الى مجتمع ذو ثقافه
متطوره وهو ايضا المجتمع الذي يهيء
الاقتصاد متطور فالاقتصاد الحديث الان
يسمى اقتصاد المعرفه اللي هو ناتج عن
التقدم العلمي والبحثي ولذلك يعني نهوض
وتطور الامم مرتبط بالاهتمام بالعمليه
التعليميه فشكرا لاهتمامكم
ما الذي ينقص اليوم العمليه التعليميه
للمضي بها قدما اكثر فاكثر خصوصا مع
التغيرات في الحالي
الحقيقه انه كل الدراسات في هذا المجال
التي تتعلق بالتنميه التنميه المجتمعيه
بشكل عام تشير الى علاقه وارتباط بين نجاح
العمليه التنمويه وبين التركيز والاستثمار
في العمليه التعليميه
وهذا امر يعني يخلق نوع من عدم الارتياح
عندما نقارن بين ما يستثمر في المنطقه
العربيه في العمليه التعليميه مقابل ما
يستثمر في دول اخرى التي نهضت وتطورت
لاسباب عديده من ضمنها الاهتمام والتركيز
على العمليه التعليميه والبحث العلمي لذلك
هذه مناسبه لدعوه جميع من لهم علاقه
باتحاد القرار في المجتمعات العربيه
بالتركيز على اولويه التعليم من الناحيه
الكميه ومن الناحيه النوعيه
التوجهات تروح مثلا بدهم يكونوا اطباء حتى
الاهل كانوا حابين انه اولادهم يكونوا
اطباء او مهندسين دائما اكثر همم تخصص كان
هل اليوم اختلفت التخصصات اختلفت التوجهات
باختلاف الظروف التي طرات علينا بفعل
التكنولوجيا وكل هذه الامور
نعم يعني في كل مرحله تختلف الاولويات همم
صحيح انه ما زالت مهنه الطب يعني هي من
المهن همم الاكثر جاذبيه ولكن الى جانب
ذلك الان نلاحظ مثلا اهتمام شديد في
الاقبال على المهن التي لها علاقه بصناعه
المعلومات والتقنيات الحديثه والاي تي
والقضايا المتعلقه بالتطور التقني
والكمبيوتر
والمعلوماتيه همم مثلا همم كليات الاي تي
مثلا همم في جامعه بيرزيت على سبيل المثال
هي التي عليها اكبر طلب مقارنه بالكليات
الاخرى الكليات المهنيه تاتي بالدرجه
الثانيه وللاسف هناك تراجع في الاقبال على
بعض
الاختصاصات المهمه مثل الاختصاصات العلميه
الفيزيائيه الكيمياء الرياضيات والتربيه
وما الى ذلك ولذلك الحكومات والجامعات
عليها ان تبذل الجهد لاحداث توازن لانه
المجتمع يحتاج جميع هذه التخصصات وجميع
هؤلاء الخريجين
السوشيال ميديا التي بدات تاخذ شيئا فشيئا
وتزيح نوعا ما الاعلام التقليدي انصح
التسميه
اعتقد بانه
الاعلام
كاختصاص اكاديمي بدا يتاقلم مع المعطيات
الجديده همم سابقا الاعلام من ناحيه
التدريس همم كان بعيدا عن التفاعل مع
متطلبات التواصل
انه الجامعات المختلفه
انا اسمعكم جيدا
كنت احاول ان اقول بانه الجامعات مؤخرا
ودوائر واقسام الاعلام بدات يعني تتاقلم
مع التطور الاخير الذي جعل من وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي هي اداء اساسيه
وبالتالي لاحظنا بانه هناك نوع من التزاوج
والتفاعل والتكامل بين همم اسس المهن
الاعلاميه
والاداء والوسائل الخاصه بالتواصل
الاجتماعي وبالتالي الانتاج الاعلامي بدا
يقدم بشكل تدريجي
واساليب التواصل الاجتماعي وهذا ما بدا
يتم التهيئه له والاعداد له في كليات
الاعلام في الجامعه
بانني محظوظه بان اكون محاطه بين
اساتذه من ال الخطيب استاذ غسان في جامعه
بيرزيت وايضا دكتور نبيل الخطيب الذي ما
في حياتنا المهنيه بعد ذلك يعني وكان احد
مدراء قناه العربيه وتتلمدنا ايضا على يده
في المجال المهني وكنا معك في المجال
الاكاديمي استاذ غسان خطيب استاذ في جامعه
بيرزيت شكرا لك على وجودك